tyler mcgill whom the mezzo played very
well behind and who's pitched extremely
well in his small number of starts but
this is a huge test tonight marcus
simeon leads off for the jays
and semi hits one on the ground
right at vr and he throws out simeon for
the first down so a one-out walk issued
to bechet just the 25th walk he's drawn
this season that'll set the table for
vladie guerrero junior full count to
guerrero and he struck him out thrown a
second by mccann the good tag by giorme
but they don't get the call great tag by
guillermo on that short hop throw looked
like mckenn was gonna get him it's a
strikeout for mcgill as he gets guerrero
but bechet steals the base is 13. runner
in scoring position with two out now
george springer and he gets one of the
air a pop-up behind short
retreating his vr weighs everybody else
away makes the catch side retire
donald mcgill works around to walk in
the first inning steven matz makes his
return to city field the first start
back at home for the left-hander since
the mets traded him away very odd to see
stephen mats in any uniform except the
orange and blue 3-1 to nemo and the
force field in effect mimo's on with the
lead off block that's 11 walks in his
last seven games that will bring up pete
alonso 1-1 pitch alonzo lines one in the
air to deep left hernandez just turns
watches it's gone
homerun number 20 for pete alonso and
the mets have a two to nothing first
inning lead 89th career home run which
ties him with gary carter on the mets
all-time home run list oh they have a
new thing you know they've got teams
with the swag chain they got the laundry
basket
the camel horse now you got the pony
here's jd davis
2 2 pitch change up and a good one
swinging a miss ass davis strikes out
two down another 3-2 pitch from steven
metz got him chased the high fastball
and strikes him out back-to-back strike
ass but the mets jump out to a
two-nothing lead but now mcgill has
retired the first two on the ground here
in the second inning kevin bitchio
coming up there's a breaking ball
hammered on the line into right field
craig bishop good to see benefit of
watching his boy come up with a base hit
first hit for the blue jays two out
single and it'll bring up the catcher
alejandro kirk
a little tapper off the mound comes
mcgill plenty of time
side retired one away here's jonathan vr
there's a change up hit on the ground
vigil was in to guard against the bun
it's an easy play for him and vr's
retired 5'3 on the put out two away so
here's guillaume left hand better
that's lined the other way and guillerme
has got an opposite field hit so they
claim to pull and he goes to left field
third base runner and it gets the
pitcher to the plate
swinging a miss that'll do it steven
matz has found his release point
throwing the ball very well now he will
leave things off for the jails steven
matz leads off the third they'll get a
nice hand from the crowd at city field
swinging a ground ball softly hit to
short vr grabs it has to hurry throw to
first in time matt's can still move down
the line he was thrown out by a step one
out nobody on it swinging a missed
strike three a good tight slider in the
dirt simeon went after it tyler mcgill
with a couple of strikeouts brandon
nimmo leads off the third against mats
and there's another good fastball
swinging at this by nimmo that's four
strikeouts now for steven matt's a
little bit of a hiccup to start the game
but he's pretty well locked in right now
there's a good change-up swing and a
miss by dominic smith steven metz with
five strikeouts through three innings
let's lead two nothing and now george
springer
lying but right at vr two out two up two
down mcgill's retired six straight now
the batter tay oscar heard endings and
hernandez goes down swinging good change
up by mcgill to get him that's three
strikeouts for tylor he's now retired
seven in a row second walk issued by
mats that snaps a string of four in a
row retie
another fast ball hit on the ground and
bow second for one back to first double
play that was a six five three double
play as
kevin biggio the third baseman was in
the shift and he took the throw at
second batter will be james mccann
swinging on the first pitch nice play at
third by vizio long throw good scoop
over at first great play on both ends
blue jays left richik biggio and kirk do
up
it's the first pitch on the ground
toward the whole cut off nicely by davis
spinner and he got it oh wow
j.d davis
with the great extension and showing off
that wonderful arm and he gets the out
on grichik
for the first out of the fifth now we've
seen each third baseman make a gem just
for the last two outs here's the other
one biggio
swing and a miss at a high hard one and
mcgill's got his fourth strikeout he's
now retired nine in a row as he gets
bigger pitcher steven metz will come up
3-2 the pitch in there strike three
called side retired he got him with a
fastball
and for mcgill his fifth strikeout no
runs a hit one left tyler mcgill will
get his second at bat
and he lines one to right field and he's
got his first big league hit tyler
mcgill in his ninth major league back
has his first safety
and they'll take that ball out of play
round of applause outstanding this crowd
has come to really appreciate tyler
mcgill in a big hurry now the mets have
runners at first and second and here
comes the maestro i suppose pete alonso
do it again gets the pop-up guerrero's
got room and foul ground and matt skins
out of it terrific job by stephen mats
to strand a pair one out of nobody on
now bobas shed
and he gets jammed and bloops went into
shallow right on comes conforto to dive
and make the cash oh wow
i didn't know the olympic diving
competition had begun yet michael
conforto makes the latest
really good defensive play in this game
and i'm talking about for both teams
this is as
good a display of defense as we've seen
in a while the one ota guerrero
fastball chopped left side charged by
the shortstop vr he's up with it throws
to first in time side retired a four
pitch sixth inning for tylor mcgill now
tyler mcgill just had a four pitch
inning he's thrown 78 pitches in six
scoreless innings but it appears that he
is done for the day here's jd davis
change up popped up over near the mets
dugout guerrero
is there and he makes the catch
two down so the mets get a two out base
runner
and that's gonna be it apparently for
steven matz with right hand hitting
james mccann coming up nice hand for a
nice homecoming for steven matt's not
exactly what he'd hoped but he pitched
well after alonso's home run but adam
simber is in to face james mccann with a
runner at first and two down
bouncing ball over the mound
the shed has time to throw out to
catcher and simber dispatches the mets
in the six randall bridge found the hole
in the shift and he's got a two out
single this inning continues for kevin
bizio
pulled down to first alonzo has a
trickle through backed up by guillory
throws to alonzo and gets the out
guillerme johnny on the spot after it
got through alonzo the 3-4-3 put out
gets lugo through the inning so one away
and here comes alonso
in the air in a deep left center and
alonso is struck again
into the second deck
an enormous home run by alonso
second of the night
there's your insurance three-nothing new
york
450 feet into the second deck and left
center he's letting that pony ride him
now we go to the ninth inning here at
city field the mets lead the blue jays
three to nothing edwin diaz comes to the
mound for the mets
the shet lines one to left and comes tom
smith and he picks it off for the out
one batter one line drive one out for
diaz
line center field nimble retreating
he's got it two out
two batters two line drives two outs
and now the jays are down to their final
strike
he struck him out and the ball game is
over
diaz gets back on the horse with a one
two three nine for the save tyler mcgill
picks up his first major league win with
six scoreless innings and the mets with
their second straight shutout